but first of all mr. Van Horn I want to
talk to you about The Witcher throughout
you got to play some of this at the end
of last week yeah like the first three
out of last week or something not really
first three hours it was like three it
we had three hours to spend with the
game okay so it they stuck us in the not
stuck us because it was good but it was
tutorial and then a little and then the
bit that comes beyond that and then they
moved us forward to do some later game
stuff so talk to us about that one of
the things I enjoyed most about your
preview was that you instantly did not
do what they told you and just ran in
the directions I jumped in the ocean
into a meadow so here's here's the
here's the real story alright so the
build that they were showing I was on I
was on the ps4 when we went in so they
had ps4 over here PC and Xbox one all
the PCs were already snatched up okay a
minute the press just swarmed into the
room how did it look on ps4 quick great
look fantastic
so I went up unfortunately I ran into a
bug that they'd already fixed which is
when you play like a card game that you
can play in a tavern the game crashed
great so Saeng I so they were like okay
we'll just we'll movie the Xbox one and
we'll just push you forward now so I got
to play the later part earlier than
everybody else and so I finished I
actually finished that quest I was like
none of the people have come back to me
to like tell me to go to the beginning
or whatever I'm just gonna go out and do
whatever the FI want what was that like
I'm just exploring if you're super cool
and and what's interesting is is that
the way they do it it's not like sort of
the Dragon Age way or the every Ubisoft
game way worse like you fill the world
with Oh stuff yeah like checkpoint yeah
and there's a like ons everywhere the
way they make you want to go out is that
they actually fill it with really cool
stuff that surprises you everywhere you
go
so what I did is I saw oh they're
Islands on the map how do I get out
there no apparently their boats in the
game mmm um but I went a so on in a
world with Islands there were also be
boats technology's wonderful things I
hate you Danny
so apparently there are boats I'm just
sick but I didn't see any boats I just
swam alright alright so like it took me
like like a good
seven eight minutes and that's an
eternity in a game you know I'm just
swimming and doing nothing else so I
finally get out there just like a fish
or like birds during this time same swim
animation there's stuff you can go
underwater and see it's not quite as
colorful as like if you do it far cry or
yeah like it actually looks like
underwater often looks yeah I'm
terrified as the place to these weird
colorful worlds that we often build
under the water that are nothing like
life it's what happened when you got to
the island so I got there and as you get
close you realize something's happening
things are there's a sound okay kind of
sound and it apparently there's it's
just like that so they're there sirens
out there so but the cool thing about
the sirens is that there's they can
plunge into the water and swim and come
after you that way okay and they also
like go into the air and fly so they
have fins and they have wings and
nowhere is there no where it's Satan
they're like sexy attack cormorants yes
Chris it's exactly like that sexy attack
so anyway you go you I get up there and
and just everywhere there's no escaping
and it gave me a good chance like first
of all I've never seen a creature like
that in a game the way they present them
and we've seen sirens before but not
this particular thing and immediately it
was like this is my reward now my next
reward Rajveer I kill it
and then once I figured out sort of how
to kill it and I had my crossbow which
is kind of new the miniature crossbow
Geralt uses to you know you can use that
underwater but I couldn't swing at these
things underwater so I'm like just
swimming away and they're nipping up my
heels
yeah but you like any terrified at any
stage because the world waits verify
it's well it's not like you know the
other school is where you everything
levels up alongside it's not you might
just run across in that that's 20 levels
high yeah and it's not like in you know
as I love love love Dragon Age
Inquisition my second favorite game last
year but I also recognize that it's you
know that combat was almost more of a
just a thing that you do that as you go
to get from now to later like you could
hold down the button and just win a lot
of the time yeah the thing I love about
what The Witcher does and what's always
done is every combat event is an actual
event
and so you have to be careful all of the
time unless you want to how much you
want to die and it also has some of that
Dark Souls feel right like you level up
and you get better at this stuff but
there's this sense that if you're good
enough even if you're low low enough
level you could probably still do this I
kept texting my family
yeah it might take you a long time
chipping down the help and rolling a lot
around and walking and whatever but you
could probably still get away with and
that's that's kind of a thing I loved
and role-playing games so it hit two of
my sweet spots number one is it made me
want to go out because I ran into
something cool like those firing on it
what other cool things are out there
right so instead of worrying you there
with an icon where there was a baby TV
do you already know what you're going to
buy because it says it on the question
mark exactly and and and the other part
was just like for dad because now all I
can think about is how long was they it
hits all the right spots for me I'm like
making combat event an event that's the
other thing like I don't want to feel
like you know as I was reading is like
the most incredibly awful hard thing to
get through every time because after a
while that's just heartbreaking yeah but
it made it feel like there was still a
potential for me to die all the time and
that's what I love and it happened a lot
as I went out elsewhere into the world
and ran into packs of this and you know
I went off to that Island there's a
treasure chest there wasn't even any
like was a treasure in it there was
treasure in it yeah but the the the the
thing that felt like the reward was the
discovery yeah that's that's really hard
to pull off and that's that's the thing
that I think they pull off really well
and the way you talk about it is really
interesting cuz you're not talking about
like I went here and discovered a thing
it's like I went here and discovered a
new type of enemy and that Andy I was
jacking me up and I had to like figure
out and discover the best way to like
fight that enemy and then once they were
done I could go about the business of
discovering what else was in that area
so it's just kind of at multiple stages
you're you know it's never never becomes
like oh I saw that thing that's really
cool now I'm just gonna do the thing
I've done a bunch too yeah yeah like
there's so much of open-world games are
known quantities they just sort of mix
the ingredients around a little bit it's
interesting because - because I feel
like it's telling stories and all these
events
like you know it's it's pretty hard to
to take game mechanics or just take a
thing like this and I mean see you like
you're telling a story with it but
already like this is the story I
remember I mean I saw a lot of cutscenes
when I played The Witcher 3 yeah but
that's the story that I came out of it
was oh my god let me tell you about the
thing I did with the sirens you know but
even some of the quests I did had like
just I did the side quest where you go
out after some ghost thing that's
haunting a well and like as you do it
like this whole story of where these
creatures come from and like the
heartbreak that leads to this kind of
spirit even existing and then when she
appears like she looks like an evil
bridesmaid and I mean we've seen oh it
was kind of that design before like the
evil bridesmaid thing right but
storytelling on that series that's
always been good but it's interesting to
see it in like an open world
yeah it's stumbling into these really
well-written stores yeah everything just
feels like these little nuggets of
interesting things and part of what
makes them interesting is that they're
just not done exactly this way in other
games and so that's what keeps you going
it's like not doing the stuff but the
quality of the stuff yeah these games I
remember playing like PC which or two
and always being a little bit sort of
having that my PC hat on and being a
little bit worried about performance and
bugs and stuff like that does this game
feel a little bit more on the polished
size it had its few moments like I said
it crashed the first yeah but they
already version obviously stuff I mean
and it has some of some of that stuff
that goes along some some weird
collision things you know sometimes the
the the sirens the AI couldn't quite
figure out what to do when it would kind
of like get stuck flapping in the water
or on the edge and little stuff like
that stuff that they're still you know
obviously working on but it did have the
feel of you know hey this is a game
that's probably gonna be complete which
which is nice considering it's already
been delayed several times yes we're
only it's in March it's set to to Friday
May is amazement perfect name yeah it
gets me I don't know like all I know is
like it you know what I played a lot and
it's just like okay you delay it as
often as you need if it means that we're
gonna get to play this really cool
finished game you know
once it comes out but I just had a
really good time with it and I like I
like that kind of world that oppressive
atmosphere which is why I love The
Witcher games in any way but I love that
oppressive atmosphere where it's like
it's amazing people I even still live
here anymore
hmm you know why why are you here this
is awful where else are they gonna go
Kevin
I mean it's just the kind of place where
it's like how do you how did you guys
not just all of you kill yourselves like
20 years ago
that's it well that's one of the
problems are lots of open more games
normal people don't seem to exist
anymore they're just it's all people
either enemies or Co combatants or all
right but this is this is this really
but it sets it up so well and the tone
of the world is everybody's just so
tired and so be left there down The
Witcher 3 lethargy and I think you get
pretty tired if like you want to go draw
water from the well but like oh that
crazy Brides ghost is back again
yes off yeah figure something else it
like this has been going on for 20 years
and I'm like how come you haven't done
anything about it now it's like well now
my daughter's sick and like all this all
this stuff is happening and now she
can't handle the water that comes from
the light comes from I don't hear about
your sick daughter yeah I got one more
question for you that is it's the one
that I keep seeing and all there's no
empathetic based I don't care about your
sick daughter just gotta go do one I
want to know has it been worked because
that's one of the things people are
worried about is coming in on consoles
now has it been what it has it bad is it
as difficult as the worst is that like
Angela Merkel's nursing me nurse no I
met Angela Merkel right Angela Angela
Merkel awful German economic hands all
over this video game yes has it become
wildly successful yet has it been
unpeaceful fide yes in the console
because that's all the PC fans are
scared of it honestly I thought for
Witcher she said to play best when I
plugged in a controller and played it on
PC and and so I know like in fact I mean
The Witcher 2 had like QuickTime events
what what more console II not PC thing
can you ask for than a QuickTime event
but no I wouldn't say that it feels that
way at all now grant but grandpa didn't
play it on PC
so it's hard for me to say hey blah blah
blah but it felt as difficult when
you're going on the Cosmo gosh yes I
mean like I said before I don't I don't
think they really even changed anything
with the witcher 2 when the witcher 2
came to consoles it was still more or
less the exact same game so what it was
it was challenging but they they get you
going better like one of the ways in the
witcher 2 you know the challenge was
just rolling around a lot yes even
though they had blocking and stuff just
rolling a real evade roll it was pretty
good and i never wonder why he didn't
stop himself with a sword during any of
those evade roles now now you can do
like four quick steps and you can do a
vaild role but carrying and blocking are
now a lot more like I actually felt like
I you know I got to parry and like I'd
knock back dudes and I'd get to slash
them for a minute yeah so that all stuff
felt a lot I wouldn't say more forgiving
but I will say it made more sense it was
a much more sensible take on the combat
system like parry being more effective
than a role cuz the role you come up
from and you have to be like poised to
make like you have your momentum in the
per club like while you're rolling the
dudes either finishing a striker looking
at you but a parry you're kind of
aggressively stopping them and moving
into an attack I always feel like parry
should be yeah it's like boxing counter
punch it's absolutely an I don't know
there's something about this game where
it feels like you should have should
always have been able to get up in its
face
and depending on how a developer handles
it like that constant rolling depending
on how they deal with collision and
stuff like that it can actually be a
kind of a get-out-of-jail-free card if
you just roll around a bit because even
though they'll be clearly hitting you
you know maybe maybe the way the
animations that they're not going to
actually damage you so this just feels
it's this great all-around
you